if radicals is something that you
struggle with this video is for you
we're gonna be going through 20 examples
covering simplifying rationalizing
radicals involving variables adding and
subtracting as well as doing a couple
equations involving radicals so let's
start off by simplifying radicals square
roots cube roots etc the first thing you
want to do is you want to figure out
like what type of a radical is it like
in this case because there's not a
number here and there's not an index we
know that this is a square root where as
for number 2 is see this is a cube root
we see the 3/4 root and then another
square root so there's two different
ways to simplify these pick which one
that you like the best but what a lot of
students like to do is they like to ask
themselves is there a perfect square
that I can divide out of 72 now you have
to know your perfect squares like 4 is a
perfect square 9 is a perfect square 16
25 36 49 64 81 100 these are good
perfect squares to memorize so in this
case I noticed that 36 goes into 72 2
times so what we can do is we can write
it as a product meaning we're
multiplying the two square roots
together 36 times 2 gives us back the
square root of 72 but square root of 36
we know that's 6 squared right so the
square root of 36 is just going to be 6
and we have a square root of 2 leftover
so remember when you're taking the
square root it's really asking you what
number times itself equals 36 well
that's going to be 6 because 6 squared
is 36 and the square root of 2 we can't
simplify because what integer times
itself is 2 it's really there isn't one
now that's one option the other option
is you can do a prime factorization tree
and I'm going to show you that method
next so what we're going to do is we're
going to break this down where to say
what goes into 72 well we know 9 and 8
and what goes into 9 that's 3 and 3 and
what goes into 8 that's going to be 4
and 2 and then what goes into 4 okay so
we're just breaking it down in a factor
tree and now what we do since we're
taking the square root is we look for
two of the same number so for example
here's a pair of two's
here's a pair of threes and we have this
two left over so for each pair for each
group here we just get one of that
quantity because this represents for the
square root of 4 is 2 this represents 9
the square root of 9 is 3 so that's how
we're just getting 1 in each group here
and we multiply them together we say 3
times 2 is 6 okay right here with 2 left
over and that stays underneath the
square root now if there was a 2 left
over and a 5 left over that would be 2
times 5 is 10 and we'd have square root
of 10 left underneath that radical it's
kind of like the remainder let's do
another example so for number 2 now
we're gonna do a cube root so see the 3
here this is called the index it's
saying what quantity times itself 3
times is equal to 48 it has to be that
same quantity 3 times right well there
really isn't anything you know like 4
times 4 times 4 that's 64 3 times 3
times 3 that's 27 so what we're gonna do
is we're going to try to divide out
perfect cubes now what are the perfect
cubes well you can memorize these
there's 8 which is 2 cubed there's 27
which is 3 cubed 64 is 4 cubed you know
etc so those are good to memorize here
what I notice is 48 is really a cube
root of 8 right so a cube root of 8
times cube root of 6 now the cube root
of 8 like we said that's 2 so we end up
with 2 and a cube root of 6 left over
and that's as far as we can go because
really there's not a perfect cube we can
divide out of 6 now a lot of students
don't like that method because you know
it involves you know some memorizing and
involve some dividing so what we're
going to do is let's just do it the way
we were doing this one up here which is
to do a factor tree we're going to break
down that number okay into its prime
factors and you keep going until you
just get a number that's only divisible
by 1 and itself
if you look at the ends of the branches
here just the ones at the ends that's
what we're looking at here if we were to
multiply 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 times
3 we'd get back 48 but because we're
taking the cube root we're gonna look
for groups of 3 now when we're doing the
square root we're looking for groups of
2 in the same number here you can see
we've got a group of three twos okay so
that's really like 8 the cube root of 8
is 2 so we just
that group and then we're left over with
two times three which is six so you can
see we're getting the exact same result
it's just a different way of doing it so
pick the method that you like the best
now for number three we're looking at a
fourth root of 80 so what do you think
for this one well you can memorize your
perfect numbers to the fourth degree for
example like 2 to the 4th is 16 and 3 to
the fourth is 81 or you can do the prime
factorization method that we did here so
let's go ahead and do that factor tree
we've got 8 and 10 8 is 4 and 2 4 is 2
times 2 and 10 is 2 times 5 now don't
make the mistake of taking some of these
numbers higher up just the ones at the
very end we're looking for groups of 4
of the same number so here you can see
we've got four twos with a 5 left over
so this is going to represent two times
the fourth root of 5 so this is kind of
like the remainder now remember if
there's a 5 and a 3 left over that would
be 15 that's what's what would remain
underneath that 4th root there okay
number 4 see if you can do this when
we're back to a square root and when
it's a square root they don't write it
but it's understood to be like a 2 right
here the index is 2 like what quantity
times itself twice is 150 let's do the
factor tree again we've got 15 times 10
15 is 3 times 5 and 10 is 2 times 5 so
you can see here's a pair of fives okay
because we're looking for groups of two
so that 5 comes out from underneath that
square root and we're left with 3 times
2 which is 6 so it's 5 square root of 6
and you got it ok let's transition now
into talking about what happens when
you're dividing or you have a fraction
or your we need to rationalize so let's
go through some examples number 5 we've
got the square root of 9 25th
so what do you do when you have a
fraction underneath that square root
sign well what you can do is you can
actually write this as square root of 9
over square root of 25 so you can
actually split up take square root of
the numerator over square root of the
denominator and then simplify them
individually so square root of 9 is just
saying what number times itself is 9
well that's going to be 3 square root of
25 is what number times itself is 25
five so you can see it simplifies down
to three-fifths okay so if we're number
six now a little bit different here
you've got square root of eighteen over
72 we can split it up into two square
roots like a square root divided by
square root like we did in this one but
sometimes what I like to do is I like to
see if I can reduce first so what I
notice is that 18 goes into 18 once and
18 goes into 72 four times so I can
really write this now as square root of
1 over square root of 4 square root of 1
we know is 1 because 1 times 1 is 1
square root of 4 is 2 because 2 squared
is 4 and so this one just works off to
1/2 so if you can simplify first then
split it up into 2 square roots
for number 7 now we've got spirit of 1/5
okay what do we do here same idea we're
going to split it up square root of 1
over square root of 5 of course we know
a square root of 1 is just 1 but what
about the square root of 5 ok now this
is interesting square root of 5 is not a
perfect square it's technically
considered improper to have a square
root in the denominator or a cube root
or a radical in that denominator so how
do we get rid of that radical well well
we can do here with the square root of 5
is we can multiply by the square root of
5 over the square root of 5 because
anything divided by itself is really
like the number 1 and 1 times this
fraction here is not going to change the
value of it it's just going to change
the way that it looks 1 times square
root of 5 is square root of 5 but square
root of 5 times square root of 5 is
square root of 25 the squared of 25 is 5
so now we've got rid of that square root
in the denominator and we just have an
integer and it's OK to have the spirit
left over in the numerator so that's
called rationalizing see this square
root of 5 is actually irrational you
can't be written as a ratio of an
integer divided by an integer it's
considered irrational we want to
rationalize it or make it rational and
we did that by multiplying the numerator
and denominator by that square root of 5
we'll look at some more examples like
that as we go so number 8 we've got cube
root now of 8 over 81 so just like we
did over here we can split it up into
cube root of the numerator
okay so cube root of 8 over cube root of
the denominator he would have 8 as 2
because 2 times 2 times 2 see 2/3 times
multiplied again
but 81 now let's break that down that's
actually 9 times 9 and 9 is 3 times 3
and this 9 is 3 times 3 but remember
we're looking for groups of three of the
same number so we have a group here so
this is going to be 3 with a 3 left
underneath that cube root okay now we
don't want this radical here in the
denominator it's considered improper but
we can't just multiply by square root of
5 like we did over here to eliminate
that radical because what we're trying
to do is we're trying to make this
quantity right here our perfect cube
basically so when we take the cube root
we get rid of that radical so notice
what we have here we have 1 3 we really
need 3 of the same number right we need
it to be a perfect cube so what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to
multiply by the cube root of 3 squared
and whatever I do to the denominator I
have to do to the numerator because
that's like multiplying by 1 so now look
what happens we have 3 to the first
times 3 to the second let me write this
down here this is going to be 2 cube
root of 3 squared over 3 times cube root
of 3 cubed okay so notice now we've got
the cube root and the third power these
are inverses of one another we're just
left with 3 now you can also think of
this as 3 cubed is 27 what's the cube
root of 27 it's 3 but we're going to
have 3 times 3 which is 9 and then over
here we've got 3 squared which is 9 so
that's the cube root of 9 and then we
have this 2 in front so it's really 2
cube root of 9 all divided by 9 we
rationalize it by getting rid of that
radical that was in the denominator okay
so that was a challenging one let's look
at number 9 this is kind of similar to
this one
this is a fourth root of 1/4 again we
can split this up we can say this is the
fourth root of 1 over the 4th root of 4
now for I'm just gonna rewrite that as 2
squared right 2 times 2 is 4 the fourth
root of 1 that's of course just gonna be
1 but here you see we don't want this
radical or this 4th root in the
denominator how many more twos do we
need well ideally we want 2 to the 4th
power because the fourth power the
fourth root those are inverses that
cancel it would just leave us with 2
we'd be happy alright so what we're
going to do is we're going to multiply
by what we're missing which is we need
two more twos so I multiplied by the
fourth root of 2-squared
whatever I do to the denominator I want
to do the numerator and now you can see
we have this is the fourth root of 4 and
the denominator we have the fourth root
of 2 to the fourth power now here you
can see these are inverses they cancel
we're just left with 2 so it's going to
be the fourth root of 4 all divided by 2
now you might be saying Mario well isn't
this too well that's the square root of
4 is 2 Bo here we're looking for the
fourth root so we've rationalized it we
got rid of the radical in the
denominator and you've got it for these
next four examples we're going to be
working with radicals involving
variables and we're going to assume that
all the variables are positive in these
examples okay so for number 10 we're
taking the square root you see there's
not an index there so it's understood to
be 2 of 4 x squared Y to the fourth is e
to the 6 now if you want what you can do
is you can break this down for is really
like 2 times 2x squared is like x times
X Y to the fourth is like 4 wise right
and Z to the sixth is like 6 Z's all
multiplied together right so we've just
broken it down and now we're taking the
square root we look for two of the same
quantity okay so here we've got a pair
of twos so that's gonna represent it's 4
and the square root of 4 is 2 right so
for each of those groups we're just
gonna get one of that quantities so this
is going to be 2 here we've got a pair
of X's okay so that's going to be X
we've got Y times y which is y squared
and here we have Z times Z times Z
that's going to be Z cubed and we
simplified it now you might say Maura
that's a lot of writing is there a
shorter way well what you can do is you
can think of this as of 2 here the
square root and what we're doing is
we're saying with these exponents here
how many times does 2 go into 2 once see
how there's an X here how many times to
go into 4 twice see Y squared how many
times does 2 go into the 6 z cubed now
that only works if you have you know
these exponents like that okay so you
can't just say like how many times does
3 go into 250 that won't work it's just
for the the ax
so we're looking for groups of two let's
look at number eleven you understand
this little bit better so this one's a
square root of 12 X cubed Y to the fifth
is e to the 11th again we don't see the
index here it's understood to be a to a
square root let's break down 12 that's
going to be 4 times 3 and 2 times 2 and
so you can see we've got a pair of twos
on we have this 3 left over so that's
gonna stay underneath that square root
okay it's kind of like the remainder
okay now over here how many times does 2
go into 3 it goes in there once with one
left over how many times does 2 go into
5
it goes in there twice with one left
over how many times this is 2 going to
11 it goes in there 5 times with one
left over and that's gonna be your final
result so that's kind of a quick way of
doing it let's look at number 12 and 13
we're working with cube roots now see
the 3 same idea we're looking for groups
of 3 but let's break down the number
here so 250 is really like 25 times 10
and 25 is like 5 times 5 and 10 is like
5 times 2 so there's a group of 3 of the
same number right so that's 5 is going
to come out on the outside of this cube
root but we have a 2 left over that
stays on the inside or underneath 3 goes
into 4 one time with one left over 3
goes into 3 one time with none left over
3 goes into 8 2 times 3 times 2 is 6
with 2 left over so see how I'm doing
that again if you want to understand it
better go ahead and write it all out
like this and then circle groups of 3
for each group of three years gonna get
1 of that quantity ok now this number 13
lucky number 13 here we've got you know
square root of a fraction so we may have
to do some rationalizing this could be a
little bit more challenging the first
thing I like to do is I like to try to
simplify what's underneath you know the
the radical here so what I could do is I
could you know try to reduce this a
little bit like for example one of these
A's would cancel with one of these A's
okay making this from a 3 to a 2 so I'm
just going to do that just as an initial
step that's about all we really can do
on this one then what we can do is we
can split it up into
cube root of the numerator so that's 16
B squared over cube root of the
denominator 81 a squared C to the fourth
okay now 16 is actually two to the
fourth power right two times two times
two times two okay but we can make one
group of three okay of those twos so
that means this would be two and we
would have a two left okay underneath we
can't make a group of three with the B
squared there's only two B's there right
so this is gonna stay underneath okay
over here 81 is 3 to the fourth power so
we could make a group of three okay so
that would be like three would come out
but then we're gonna be left with one
three underneath that cube root we can't
make a group of three with the A's when
we have two we kind of make a group of
three with the C's so that one comes out
and there's 1c left over so 3 goes into
4 once with one remaining okay now we
don't want this cube root in the
denominator it's considered improper
right so how do we get rid of it well we
need to ask ourselves a question okay
like how many more threes do I need how
many more A's do I need how many more
C's do I need so that this becomes a
perfect cube root okay so we will really
want three of these total so how many
more do we need to multiply by well
we're gonna need to multiply by three
squared because that'll give us you know
1 plus 2 which is 3 threes okay we're
gonna need one more a we've got 2 so we
need one more and here we have one C
we're going to need two more so we get a
total of three again remember whatever
you do to the denominator you're gonna
want to do the same thing to the
numerator because this is really like
multiplying by one okay so now that's
getting interesting right so this is
three cubed but the cube root of 3 cubed
is three times this 3 is 9 and then here
we have a squared times e to the first
is 8 cubed but the cube root of a cubed
is a and then here we have C times C
squared which is C cube the cube root of
C cubed is C but then multiplied by this
C that's going to give us C squared it
came in the numerator we've got 9 that's
not a perfect cube times 2 this is not a
perfect cube 18 is not a perfect cube so
this is really just going to be the cube
root of 18 let's see we've got a B
squared and C squared so a B squared C
squared
and then we have this 2 left over in
front now sometimes when you get to this
point where you've rationalized it you
don't have a radical in the denominator
you may be able to reduce like what's
outside of the radicals like for example
this was a 3 & a 9 I could reduce those
and so you always want to look to see if
you can simplify further but this is as
far as we can go on now now we're going
to talk about rationalizing the
denominator we talked about this earlier
but that was when there was only a
monomial one term in the denominator now
we're going to talk about when there's a
binomial two terms in the denominator
how do we get rid of that radical in the
bottom in the denominator well we use
something called the conjugate and what
you do to get rid of that you know
square root in the denominator is you
multiply by that conjugate and in this
case this is going to be one plus the
square root of two if this was one plus
square root of two then I multiplied by
one minus square root of two so it's the
same two terms but you're just changing
the sign in between just that one sign
in between whatever you do to the
denominator though you have to multiply
the numerator by the same thing because
really this whole thing is like 1 1
times this is going to be the same it's
just going to be a little bit different
the way that it looks so all we're gonna
do now is we're going to distribute the
4 4 times 1 is 4 and 4 times square root
of 2 is 4 square root of 2 now some
people make the mistake and they say oh
that's the square root of 8 well
remember this is really important
distinction here when you multiply a
number times a number you get a number
right when you multiply a square root
times a square root you multiply what's
on inside of those square roots if you
multiply like a number times the square
root you just put them next to each
other side by side and if you multiply
like a number radical like a times
another number radical like this you'd
multiply the numbers together 2 times 4
is 8 and then the square roots together
square root of 3 times square root of 3
is square root of 9 and you can simplify
from there so it's kind of like
multiplying like terms okay
so that's what happened here 4 times 1
is 4 and then here plus 4 root 2 in the
denominator though you can see you have
a binomial times a binomial
you can foil if you know that acronym
first outside inside last or you can
distribute twice so first if I
distribute the 1 1 times 1 is 1 1 times
square root of 2 is just square root of
2 and then negative root 2 times 1 is
negative square root of 2 and negative
root 2 times positive 2 is a negative
square root of 4
of course the square root of 4 is 2 so
you can see the positive root 2 and the
negative you're to cancel this is minus
2 plus 1 which is negative 1 see how
there's not a square root in the
denominator more so we rationalize that
we got rid of that radical on the bottom
and then what you can do is as long as
you divide both of these by negative 1
that's going to be negative 4 minus 4
root 2 and that's as far as we can
simplify that one so let's see if we can
do this one here number 18 3 minus
square root of 3 over 5 plus square root
of 3 what would you multiply by here
well since this is plus we're going to
multiply by 5 minus square root of 3
whatever we do to the denominator we
want to do to the numerator here what we
do is we've got binomial times a
binomial in both numerators and the
denominators we're gonna have to foil
this out so let's go ahead and do that 3
times 5 is 15 right 3 times negative
square root of 3 is a negative 3 square
root of 3 negative root 3 times 5 is a
negative 5 square root of 3 and negative
root 3 times negative 3 is positive
square root of 9 but the square root of
9 we know is 3 right one thing you'll
notice is when you multiply a square
root times itself you get the number
underneath just for square roots not for
cube roots see because this is really
like 3 squared the square root of 3
square root those are inverses they
cancel giving us just 3 okay so now
that's the numerator for the denominator
same thing we've got 5 times 5 is 25
square root of 3 times negative square
root of 3 is just negative 3 and then
you can see the inside and outside
cancel 5 or 3 and negative 5 root 3
cancel so that's why I just did the
first and the last kind of like a
shortcut right so 25 minus 3 gives us a
denominator of 22 and the numerator of
15 plus 3 is 18 and we have negative 8
square roots of 3 notice that all of
these are divisible by 2 so if I divide
everything by
- this is gonna be 9 - 4 square root of
3 all divided by 11 and that's about as
far as we can simplify it out ok last
two problems we're gonna talk about
simplifying and solving radical
equations and if you want to see any
more about what we did today in this
lesson I'll put a link at the end of
this video to a playlist with all my
radical videos in there so you can kind
of sift through that and pick all the
ones that you want more practice with
but for number 19 what we want to do
here is you want to get the square root
or the radical by itself on one side of
the equal sign on one side of the
equation so I'm going to do is I'm going
to think about working from the outside
in towards that square root and I'm just
gonna keep doing the inverse operation
so I'm going to subtract 3 so that gives
us 6 and so now we have 2 square root of
x - 2 I want to get that skirt by itself
so I'm going to divide both sides by 2
so that gives us 3 and then now what's
the opposite of taking the square root
of something well that's going to be to
square it so if we square both sides the
square and the square root cancel and 3
squared is 9 so if we add 2 to both
sides you can see x equals 11 now when
you're working with these radical
equations sometimes you get an answer
that's called an extraneous solution or
extraneous root so you always want to
check to make sure that this works by
putting it back into the original
equation so let's do that real quick 11
minus 2 is 9 the square root of 9 is 3
3 times 2 is 6 plus 3 more is 9 it works
so we know that 11 is a good solution
there sometimes we'll get two solutions
and one might work and one might not
work or they both might not work and
there's no solution you just have to
check for number 20 though this is kind
of a more challenging one because we've
got two square roots here what do we do
in this situation well what you want to
do is you want to isolate one of the
square roots on one side of the equal
sign
so I'm going to subtract square root of
x from both sides just to get one of
these square roots by itself so square
root of x plus 3 equals 3 minus square
root of x now to get rid of this square
root I'm going to square the left side
but I also have to square the right side
to keep it balanced right here the
square on the square root cancel giving
us just X plus 3 here some students make
a mistake of squaring 3 and then
squaring the square root of that
but because this is a binomial meaning
two terms we have to multiply it by
itself like that so it's really going to
be three times three which is nine and
we've got let's see so we're doing three
times three is nine we've got three
times negative square root of x which is
negative three root of x we got another
negative three square root of x and then
we have negative square root of x times
negative square root of x which is just
positive x because a negative times a
negative is a positive square root of x
times square root of x is square root of
x squared which is just X right okay so
that equals x plus three now let's
simplify a little bit here we've got
nine minus six square root of x plus X
so I just combined those and now we want
to do is we want to get this square
square root here by itself on one side
of the equation so I'm going to do is
I'm going to subtract nine and I'm going
to subtract X from both sides of the
equation so I do that those cancel here
these X's cancel so we get negative 6
equals negative 6 square root of x I can
divide both sides by negative 6 so that
gives us a square root of x and this
gives us 1 and if we square both sides
x equals 1 now how do we know if that's
a good solution here let's put it back
into the original equation 1 plus 3 is 4
the square root of 4 is 2 over here
square root of 1 is 1 and 2 plus 1 does
equal 3 so we know that that's the
correct answer
so if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more follow me over to that
playlist there with more radical videos
I know we'll do some more examples in
those videos